jean paul gaultier bonsoir alors
gauthier sa vie son oeuvre tu publies
tes mémoires ça y est sous forme de
roman photo
ça s'appelle à nous de la mode et ça
s'est passé comment c'est quoi la génèse
de cette affaire bah ce qui s'est passé
c'est que bon on m'avait déjà proposé
plusieurs fois de 2,2 de faire un livre
d'écrire un livre
et puis en fin de compte quand je me
sens pas du tout capable d'écrire et j'y
suis même pas capable d'écrire aux
cartes postales
j'ai du mal j'ai beaucoup mal j'hésite
et tout ça prend trop de temps alors du
coup je le fais pas bon allez limite les
croix c'est ce que je peux faire je
crois
on a eu un coup de fil après je crois de
françoise verny 10 ans justement qu'elle
voulait faire un livre ou que j'écrive
un livre moi je vais disent impossible
alors y avait la ressource bien sûr du
du du maigre way que je n'apprécie pas
tellement parce qu'en fin de compte je
pensais un peu mentir quoi alors donc
bombe à la seule chose dont j'ai
réfléchi je me suis dit non c'est pas
possible je vais pas envie non plus un
livre avec oui parce que pour moi la
mode c'est quoi parce que c'était parler
de la mode évidemment d'amos et les
images avant tout je suis un enfant des
images
j'aime la télé j'aime le cinéma je ne
lis pas alors que les gens en lisant un
livre s'ennuie comme moi je pourrais
m'ennuyer en en lisant un j'avais pas
tellement envie donc je vais montrer des
images alors je me suis dit le roman
photo de toi c'est très bien alors
scénarios patrick rambaud conseillère
monique pivot est une spécialiste des
éditions mondiales qui fait tous ces
journaux à la perfection
ça vaut pas cher en plus c'est rigolo
ouais 95 points c'est la wii alors il ya
aujourd'hui c'est en couleurs je discute
avec jean teulé de copains de bernard
rapp et puis après tout les flash back
en noir et blanc alors il ya la vocation
de voix maquille et on nous tue mais qui
est vraiment en outre c'est vrai un j'ai
encore l'ours qui est là et tout c'est
un petit
parce que je vous ai soumis subir un
petit peu tout ce qui se passait à
l'époque c'était l'époque où il y avait
une opération à coeur ouvert professeur
barnard gelot pérenne alors pas à coeur
ouvert un petit peu là au milieu là et
qu avec des épingles je repoussais eelv
et le mariage de favols fabiola et de du
roi baudouin paraissent mariait voilà
alors il ya des foules et et fabiola il
ya d'autres fois il est tout dépend des
de l'humeur alors ouais t'as mais mes
cheveux bleus des couleurs et puis alors
ton père dont il n'a pas le beau rôle à
ben non oh là là mais là je mettais mes
parents il faut jamais quand même été
très riche en avant cela les
dentellières sévère quand même bah oui
c'est parce que c'est la version
italienne de mon père et les triturer
l'évaluent macho il ya un truc très
rigolo ça me fait penser à la pub de guy
degrenne tu sais à un moment tu es en
classe et puis on shoppe en train de
dessiner des pépés infâme avec des
corses et des trucs ne ferai jamais rien
donc monsieur guy degrenne exactement
c'est un petit peu ça ouais je crois que
pas mal de guy degrenne non dans plein
de domaines en fin de compte si tu es ça
c'est à dire que je dessinais comme moi
je regardais tout le temps la télé ma
grand mère quand même que génial me
laissait voir tout la télévision dans
les jours qui avaient le rectangle blanc
j'ai tout lu qing dame d'amiens ce dim
dam dom bon ça c'est c'était plus tard
ça c'était vraiment c'est la bimbo est
ce qu'un pour moi bon il y avait aussi
avec la mer à exclure les dents y avait
un oui aussi le théâtre de la jeunesse
qui était très bien sans télé sans t abx
général ça c'était vraiment rien à
redire et je regardais tous et je
regardais aussi même des films qui
étaient interdits et notamment une
émission sur je crois la dernière revue
des folies bergère est donc là j'avais
vu toutes ces femmes en plus mais avec
des bas résilles j'avais redessiné ça le
lendemain à l'école donc bon et puis ça
fait pas tellement plus quoi lassitude
crise alors du coup je vais faire tout
le tour pour montrer le dessin que
j'avais fait mais moi j'étais fier bon
alors on te souhaite beaucoup de succès
avec ce bouquin plus qu'avec ton disque
mais méritée 1 à succès comme ça j'ai
quand même vendu 42
c'est vrai oui et j'ai été 52e presque
contre 35 ans voilà vraiment il a fallu
une semaine d'arrêter l'australie c'est
johnny dira toute ma vie d'acheter alors
dans ton roman photo à la fin on voit
tout et amie rita mitsouko il va tornay
on voit frédéric leur cabane perdue qui
travaille avec toi et 7 yvette horner tu
l'a relooké complètement tu l'as tu l'a
complètement revampé faut bien le dire
maintenant c'est madonna alors là
changement de changement de triple à bah
oui oui le premier point commun c'est
d'abord que je suis un fan aussi bien
d'yvette horner que de madonna c'est
elle qui a appelé ses airs british c'est
lui et puis après il m'a donné le numéro
pour que je les rejoigne et puis alors
me direz c'est comment on peut citer
j'étais au bord de l'apoplexie quand je
le savoir en plus c'est génial parce que
c'est à dire i want to speak to be king
avec son accent les hyper rigolote
lorsqu'elle vraiment bien alors après
être allé la voir à new york
voilà et puis ça c'est c'est vrai
qu'elle a un frère avec elle qui est un
peu à madonna ce qu orlando était à
dalida c'est à dire qui la protège un
peu
il a protégé les là il lui donne
quelques avis comme ça quelques touches
mais elle fait ce qu'elle veut enfin je
veux dire quand même c'est assez
étonnant parce que c'est elle allait
absolument pas diriger c'est elle qui
décide qui dit ça ça va ça va pas jouer
cela c'est elle qui est produit par
exemple son prochain tour et bombe à son
frère il est là pour lui donner quelques
par exemple à un moment j'avais proposé
mois parmi tous les contenus je vais
proposer comme une vraie vierge madone
et tout et je pensais un moment qu'elle
pourrait aller sous une douche et puis
du roller enfin que sa nudité se révèle
comme ça par le vêtement transparent et
tout ça je lui plaisais beaucoup mais le
frère lui il était où ils iront même
avec avec la religion avec l'aqmi prieur
quelques petits problèmes dont fernand
sponsoring de pepsi et coca oui voilà la
pizza est paraît-il à nouveau ses voeux
non non pas du tout pièce qu'elle
discutait peu nuancé elle c'est elle
c'est ça qui est assez improbable c'est
une vraie business woman quoi elle est
dure en affaires à les malignités avis
quand même je veux dire une chose c'est
que quand je les fais je me suis dit et
tant pis si je gagne rien là dessus ça
me plaît et tous bords ya des tas de
choses que j'aurais pu gagner vraiment
mal et en artois jean-paul oui oui je
compte la domination après les venues en
france te voir et allait venir à noël
juste aux fêtes de fin d'année et a
passé le réveillon avec elle voilà et
warren beatty étaient pas là il n'était
pas l' effet la blanche quand même alors
quand aller faire les essayages elle
avait perdu 6 kilos ben voilà c'est cela
c'est que à peine parce que faisait tout
l'entraînement et tout ce qu'il ya de
génial quand même c est incroyable c'est
qu'elle s'entraîne tous les jours
bon ça c'était la préparation aussi de
son choix je crois que dans sa vie de
tous les jours elle est hyper tu vois
genre health food large et ariel
macrobiotique même de l'eau sur un
martini de temps en temps et yantaï
écoute je n'essaie pas les mesures en
tête quand je peux te dire qu'elle a une
petite taille qu'elle est
malheureusement pour moi c'est à 36 je
dirais parfaitement portionné avait pas
grand d'un mètre soixante cinq 65 avec
tes belles c'est pour lui une belle
poitrine donc parfaitement à c'est un
petit bijou qui te plaît allez super
alors elle vient à paris là au mois de
juillet moi j'irai voir tous les
concerts je ne quitterai mais at-il été
pas jean paul gaultier bah je sais pas
en fin de compte
j'ai pas non j'ai pas vraiment de héros
comme ça où on fait tous les jours